Green Coca-Cola... and 5 other everyday myths
1.
Myth: Coca-Cola used to be green.
In fact, the original formula for Coca-Cola
was also brown like it is today.
The whole “Coca-Cola was green” myth started
around the same time Coca-Cola was commonly
sold in green bottles.
(QF 681)
2.
Myth: Bulls are enraged by the color red.
In fact, bulls are red-green colorblind.
As illustrated by MythBusters, whether the
cape used in bullfighting is red or any other
color, the bull doesn’t react differently.
What gets them to charge aggressively, outside
of embedding things like banderillas (barbed
“little flags”) in their necks, is actually
the movement of the cape, not the color.
The myth that the color red enrages bulls
likely stems from matadors traditionally using
red capes going all the way back to the 18th
century in Spain.
(QF 720)
3.
Myth: Women Don’t Have Adam’s Apples.
In fact, Adam’s Apples on women aren’t
that terribly uncommon if you were to look
close enough to most women’s throats, though
“man sized” Adam’s Apples are somewhat
rare in these cases.
The “Adam’s Apple” is really just an
enlarged larnyx which becomes big enough to
be visible in your neck.
For those of you who don’t know, the larnyx’s
primary purpose is as a voice box.
It also has an alternative purpose in aiding
in the process of closing off the airways
in your throat when you swallow.
This is why it generally seems to disappear
when you swallow, as it is being pulled upward
to aid in this process.
Around puberty, both men and women’s voice
boxes get bigger.
This in turn makes their voices deeper, with
men’s larynges growing more than women’s
and thus making for a deeper voice, typically.
4.
Myth: TNT and Dynamite are the same thing.
In fact, TNT and dynamite are not the same
thing at all, contrary to what the Road Runner
and Wiley coyote would have you believe.
Dynamite doesn’t actually contain TNT, but
rather is comprised of an absorbent mixture
soaked in nitroglycerin, which is extremely
sensitive to shock, unlike TNT; this is then
wrapped in paper and voila, dynamite.
TNT or trinitrotuluene is a yellow chemical
compound that was originally used as a yellow
dye, but later was used as an explosive material
due to a variety of convenient features it
has, such as being very safe to transport.
5.
Myth: James Doohan was Scottish.
In fact, Doohan was Canadian and a very successful
voice actor before his role in Star Trek.
When he was auditioning for the role of the
ship’s engineer on Star Trek, he went over
various accents for Gene Roddenberry for the
character.
After he finished, Roddenberry asked him which
he liked best and he responded: “Well, if
you want an engineer, he better be a Scotsman
because, in my experience, all the world’s
best engineers have been Scottish.”
Although he wasn’t Scottish, Doohan described
the character of Scotty as: “99% James Doohan
and 1% accent.”
“It was a natural.
When I opened my mouth, there was Scotty.
Scotty is the closest to Jimmy Doohan that
I’ve ever done.”
6.
Myth: A “heart attack” and “cardiac
arrest” are the same thing.
In fact, “Cardiac arrest” simply implies
the heart has stopped pumping blood.
On the other hand, a heart attack is a lack
of blood flow to a specific area of the heart
caused by some blockage, spasm, or rupture
in your “pipes”.
People who have a heart attack are significantly
more likely to survive than those who suffer
cardiac arrest.
So while both are bad, cardiac arrest is worse,
unless you really didn’t like the person
whose heart stops, then it could be good.
It’s all about looking on the bright side!